>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washingotn, D.C.
>> Many of you probably already
know and love author, illustrator,
Mike Curato, for his beautifully
illustrated Little Elliot books,
about the adventures of
a polka-dotted elephant.
All the Way to Havana,
Mike Curato's newest book,
with author Margarita Engle,
follows a young Cuban boy
on a road trip with his family.
All the Way to Havana just
came out this past week.
After his talk, you could say hi to
Mike, and have him sign your book
from 12:30 to 1:30 p.m.
in the book signing area.
So, without further ado,
let's put our hands together
and give a warm welcome
to Mike Curato.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi everyone.
Hi! How are you doing?
Good? Yeah?
You want to go on a road trip today?
This is nice, because you
get to just sit in side,
and go on a road trip, right?
Okay we've got a lot to see today.
So I am going to be speaking,
and you can follow along
on the screen, okay?
And this is called All the Way
to Havana, and it is written
by my friend, Margarita Engle,
and this is a book about going
from the country to the
city, and then later,
I'm going to read you my new Little
Elliot book, about being in the city
and going to the country.
So, okay here we go!
Here are the end papers here.
See all these old cars?
They're old American cars, and in
Cuba, they have a lot of them there.
And you can see a whole bunch
of different types
here on the end papers.
Okay. And do we-- do we actually
have a copy of the book with us?
No? Okay. All right.
>> I have a copy!
>> Oh, you do?
Great, thank you so much.
It's hard to read from over here.
Okay.
Okay so here is our title page.
And Margarita is-- oh, I'm
sorry, can we back up the slide?
Thank you.
Okay, so Margarita
dedicated this book:
[ Speaking Spanish ]
>> And that means, for my cousins,
and for my nieces and nephews.
And I dedicated this book,
[speaking Spanish], and that means
for Eric, my traveling brother.
My travel buddy.
Okay, here we go.
We have a gift and we have a
cake, and today we are going
to drive all the way to the big
city to see my new baby cousin
on his zero year birthday.
So this is a farm in Cuba.
Some of this island's old cars purr
like kittens, but ours is so tired
that she just chatters
like a busy chicken.
Cada-cada [assumed spelling],
cada-cada, cluck, cluck, cluck!
Today, Cada-cada sounds
like a tiny baby chick.
Pio-pio-pio-pio [assumed spelling].
Pfff [assumed spelling]!
Papa opens the trunk and lets
me hand him the heavy tool box.
Then, he raises the hood to
show me all the rattling parts
that have been fixed
with wire, tape,
and mixed up scraps of dented metal.
See that on the right there?
That's an engine inside the car.
And the car is so old, and it
breaks down sometimes, and in Cuba,
they can't get new parts for
the cars, so they use parts
from all these different machines.
Whatever works.
He listens to each tapping
taka-taka noise that cada-cada makes
as together we struggle to
fix all the grunts, squeals,
and grumbling clunk-clunks that
should be busy cluck-cluck-clucks!
I choose a wrench, and
a bolt, and a belt.
No luck, but we keep
trying and trying,
even though all the silly noises
are still a mystery unsolved.
We don't give up.
We experiment.
We invent.
A twist here.
A tightening there.
Move this, hold that.
Try one way, then the other, until
finally after discouraging minutes
that feel like endless hours,
cada-cada once again begins
to sound like a chattering hen.
The road is bumpy, and our
noisy car ends up so crowded
with friendly neighbors
who need a ride,
that I feel like we are traveling
in a barrel of elbows and knees.
But we have a gift, and we
have a cake, and we are driving
to my new baby cousin's
zero-year birthday.
So we purr, cada-cada,
and we glide, taka-taka.
And we zoom!
Zoom! Zoom!
Cluck-cluck-cluck, beside farms,
forests, beaches and forts.
Toward the curved road by the
sea wall, where Mama points
out noisy old cars of every color.
Yellow, pink, purple, green,
orange, and even a bright red car,
with huge fins, like
a lurking shark.
I am glad that cada-cada
is peacefully blue,
like the clear sky above,
and the wide sea beyond.
Some of the noisy old cars
around us have torn seats,
shattered windows,
and cracked mirrors.
Many of the cars roar,
growl, whine, or putt-putt.
But most just honk, honk, honk!
As they glide, bumpety-bump
on potholed city streets.
Where people lean over
crumbling balconies
as laundry dances, and
a sea breeze sings.
When we finally reach Tia's house,
I hug Abuelo, and everyone smiles,
as we admire the funny baby boy
who is too little to know how
to open a gift, or play
with a box, and a ribbon,
or build a teetering
mango and pineapple tower.
After lunch, cake, music,
and a happy birthday fiesta,
I need a quiet siesta,
but when I wake up,
I discover that it is already
time to start driving home.
So we zoom, and bump all the
way back to our little village,
where we will soon have
a chance to cada-cada,
taka-taka, pio-pio, clunk!
Sleep.
The next morning, we have
to work under the hood,
once again, never giving up.
Never losing hope.
I am eager to help Papa
guess which tool is best.
When he asks me which
city trip car I like most,
the answer is easy, our car!
This noisy blue one with its
ragged seats, and cloudy windows,
because cada-cada already
belonged to our family on the day
when my Abuelo, my old grandpa,
celebrated his zero-year birthday.
Someday, Abuelo's car will be
yours, Papa promises, making me feel
as proud and as powerful
as the bold eagle
that makes cada-cada's sky
blue hood look so brave.
So, that is Margarita's and
my story, and at the end
of [applause begins] the
book, thank you, thanks!
And at the end of the book,
we each wrote a little note,
kind of explaining more about
why Cuba has all these cars,
and I wrote about going there,
and doing research for this book,
which I want to show
you a little bit of now.
Okay, so here is our
book's journey, right?
Our book went on a long road trip.
Here is our editor, Laura Godwin.
She had a bright idea.
She is like, "I think
there should be a book."
So she told Margarita and me, "Hey,
why don't you two make it for me?"
And we said, "Sure."
So there is Margarita, and she
started out by writing the story.
And then I get the story, and so
Margarita, she grew up spending half
of her time in Cuba, and half
of her time in the States.
But I am not Cuban, and
I had never been there,
and so I thought it was important
for me to find out what it is
like there, so I can
make a really good story.
And see that circle down there?
There is Cuba, just
south of Florida, there.
So I went all the way down there,
with my friend Eric,
who was my translator.
There we are.
And there is the real cada-cada.
She is real.
We took a road trip.
Here are some photos I
took all over Cuba, right?
So they helped me make my drawings.
And here is where it all starts,
I start with these really
messy, sloppy drawings.
Right? What is all that?
It is just a bunch
of scratches, right?
But I am just thinking about
different compositions,
about like how each
page will look maybe?
And this one is getting a little
bit better, and then I take a bunch
of my photos, and I paste
them together in photo shop.
And then I make my drawing, while
I'm looking at those photographs.
And then, here comes the color.
So, some of the color is digital,
and then some of it is
paint that I scan in.
And some of it comes from
the photographs that I took,
so I could get the textures
from all the buildings
and the roads, and the cars.
Oh, there is the sky.
And this building here, that is the
Flatiron building in New York City.
That is where our publisher is.
Just to remind us that even
though Margarita wrote it,
and I illustrated it, it takes a
lot of people to make one book.
A whole lot of people.
And that is where they work, in
that weird triangle building.
Okay, so we don't have a lot
of time left, but I am going
to read Fall Friends,
and then we are going
to do some drawing together, okay?
Okay! So, this is my other book.
This is the book about going
from the city to the country.
Does anyone here know Little Elliot?
Anyone? I see a few
people, all right.
So he is my buddy, and
Mouse is Elliot's buddy.
And they are going on
a fall trip together.
Okay. So. Little Elliot
and his best friend, Mouse,
loved living in the big city.
But sometimes the city was too
dirty, too loud, and too busy.
"We need a vacation," said Mouse.
This is my worst nightmare
here, on the right page,
you have to be very careful
walking your cupcakes home,
otherwise birds might
descend upon you.
I'm so sorry, do we have
the Little Elliot book?
Anyone?
[ Background Conversations ]
>> No? Okay.
I am so sorry, I can't read the
screen, maybe I need new glasses.
Okay.
Okay, thanks for bearing
with me, here.
Okay, here we go.
Later that morning, Elliot and Mouse
boarded a bus bound for the country.
They could see the
bright autumn leaves,
as the big city slowly
disappeared behind them.
Elliot and Mouse got off the
bus and smelled the fresh air.
"Wow!" said Elliot, "The country
is even bigger than the city!"
"I'll race you up that
hill," said Mouse.
At the top of the hill, Elliot
and Mouse could feel the breeze,
and the sunshine, and
the soft grass.
Oh, there we go.
Neither spoke for a long time.
Then, Elliot's stomach growled.
"I am getting hungry," he said.
"Looks like there are some apple
trees down there," said Mouse.
"The country is delicious,"
said Elliot.
"And fun," said Mouse.
"Let's play hide-and-seek!"
First, Mouse found Elliot
hiding in a hollow log.
Then, Elliot found Mouse
hiding in a pumpkin patch.
Elliot picked the perfect
hiding place.
"Mouse will never find
me here," he thought.
Elliot was right!
He waited, and waited,
but Mouse never came.
Where could Mouse be?
Elliot thought.
Everything was still.
Very still.
Suddenly, Elliot smelled
something delicious.
Something that smells so good must
be worth looking for, he thought.
What is that in the window?
Some pie? "I found you," said
Mouse, sweeping from behind the pie.
"Mouse!" said Elliot.
"When I couldn't find
you, my new friends
and I baked a pie," said Mouse.
"I told them you would
follow your nose."
"Nobody knows me better,"
said Elliot.
Later, they all gathered
for a fall feast.
"To new friends," said Mouse.
"And to new treats," said Elliot.
That night, Elliot and
Mouse nestled into the hay
and took turns naming the stars,
until they both fell fast asleep.
The end.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Okay, so now, I thought
it would be fun
if we could maybe draw our own
little Elliot story together.
Okay? All right.
So, what I am going to do,
I am going to start out,
I'm going to write a sentence here.
I am going to show
you how I draw Elliot,
and you can tell me what I
need to draw in the background,
to go along with our story, okay?
All right.
Can you hear me?
Yeah? Okay.
All right.
So, what should Elliot do today?
What do you think?
How about, Little Elliot
read a book?
All right, here we go.
Here is how I draw Elliot.
See, here is an ear...and
there is his trunk.
And a mouth, some eyes...there
is his head.
Draw an arm here, we'll
draw our book.
Okay. This is the other hand.
Some pages.
His legs. And a tail.
There is our guy.
Okay. Thanks.
All right [applause], what else.
What else should I draw?
Who is Elliot going
to read a book to?
Who do you think?
>> Mouse!
>> Mouse, yeah!
Here is Mouse.
[ Background Conversations ]
>> Okay. What else.
What else should I draw
in the background here,
for our story, what do you think?
What do you think?
What is that?
>> Some bookshelves.
>> Some bookshelves, oh yeah!
Maybe they're in a library?
Yeah?
>> Yeah!
>> All right.
They are sitting in the
Library of Congress.
Just reading a few giant books.
Here is a really big
bookshelf here, all right.
Here are some books behind him.
Okay. All right.
So you've got the idea.
Okay, I think we've got time
for maybe one or two more?
All right.
So what do you think?
What else should Elliot do today?
What do you think?
[ Inaudible Responses ]
>> Oh, he's got to ride
the bus to the library?
Okay, sure.
Little Elliot rode the bus.
All right.
Here we go.
Okay, so first, let's draw Elliot.
A library bus?
Well that would be a cool idea.
Have you ever seen
a Bookmobile before?
>> Yeah!
>> Yeah?
>> Bookmobile!
>> [Laughs] Okay, here is Elliot.
Okay, so, we need to
draw the bus, right?
Okay. So...we can't fit
the whole bus on here,
but, I'm getting an idea.
Here is a big tire, right?
All right.
And here is the door, into the bus.
Here are some stairs.
Here is the windows, so the driver
can look out, and some lights.
>> I know!
>> Here are some other windows!
>> Okay, what?
What else?
[Overlapping responses] Yeah?
That's right, in and out.
Yeah, we'll draw some
people in here.
Let's see.
This person is reading
the newspaper.
Let's see...
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> This lady is reading a book.
>> And a bus driver!
>> The bus driver is
very important, yes.
All right.
Here is the bus driver.
>> Has to be a Metro bus.
>> It could be a Metro bus.
>> It could be a Metro
bus, like we rode.
>> Oh yeah?
All right, here is our bus
driver, she is up there.
Okay. Where is this bus going?
The Library.
The library bus.
All right.
Cool, what else, here we
need our bus stop sign.
>> What about Mouse?
>> Yeah, what about Mouse?
Where is that Mouse?
Mouse is already getting
on the bus here.
>> Need a window so
he can [inaudible]--
>> [Laughs] All right.
Great! Okay.
We've got two more minutes, we'll
do a really fast one [applause].
Thank you!
All right, any more ideas?
What do you think?
Real quick?
>> Playground!
>> The playground?
Okay, yeah.
Elliot went to the playground.
And what did he do
at the playground?
[Overlapping responses]
He went on the swings?
All right.
Here comes Elliot on the swings.
We've got one more minute.
All right.
Now. Let's see.
All right, there is his arm.
We have got to hurry,
we're running out of time.
There is another arm.
There is the swing.
All right.
And where is Mouse?
Where is Mouse?
Mouse went on a swing too.
There is a swing-- where's Mouse?
>> He went flying off!
>> Mouse is airborne!
That's what I tried to do as a
kid, every day on the playground.
I never succeeded, but Mouse
fulfilled all my dreams.
Thank you so much everyone
[applause], you've been awesome.
>> I like your drawing!
>> Have a great weekend!
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.